Danke. Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özüvollü. Ich bin auf dieser Station als
Assistanarzt tätig. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch durchführen. Alles
in Ordnung für Sie.
Das ist nötig, glaubt, sagt jemand, guckt nach mir.
Ja, als erstes brauche ich ein paar persönliche Daten, dann können wir weiterführen, wenn
Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, lassen Sie mich bitte wissen.
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Antje Niehof.
Antje Niehof.
Frau Niehof, könnten Sie mir bitte Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Vorname Antje, A-N-T-J-E.
J-E.
Und Niehof, N-I-E-H-O-F-F.
H-O-F-F, Antje Niehof.
Vielen Dank, Frau Niehof. Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 38 Jahre.
38 Jahre.
Wann genau, wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 01.08.87 geboren.
87, vielen Dank. Und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Niehof?
Ich bin 1,67.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Niehof?
Ja, ich wiege so 63 Kilo.
63 Kilo.
Okay. Frau Niehof, was für Sie ist für uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, ich habe seit Tagen so heftige Kopfschmerzen und Nackenschmerzen,
dass ich also, es tut so weh, ich kann kaum noch schlafen und ich kann mich auch ganz schlecht bewegen.
Es wird immer schlimmer und das brennt hinten im Nacken und der Kopf tut mir so weh.
Ich habe schon Tabletten genommen und das hat aber auch nicht geholfen.
Und ich fühle mich halt auch so, ich bin ganz steif, ich kann mich überhaupt gar nicht bewegen
und der Kopf tut wirklich seit Tagen jetzt weh.
Okay. Sie haben schon gesagt, seit ein paar Tagen.
Wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen begonnen?
Ja, es hat angefangen, ich muss mich überlegen. Ja, vor vier Tagen hat es angefangen.
Vor vier Tagen.
Und jetzt ist es eigentlich auch, es wird immer schlimmer und jetzt strahlt es hier so in den Arm sogar rein.
Der Arm tut mir auch ein bisschen weh.
Welche Seite?
Der linke Arm.
Den linken Arm.
Strahlende Schmerzen, den Nacken und den linken Arm.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Und ich kenne das überhaupt gar nicht. Also es ist wirklich sehr unangenehm.
Frau Nykhoff, wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Siehung, Druckung, Stichung?
Also es brennt und es bohrt, also im Kopf bohrt es ja.
Und die Schmerzen sind auch so, also die letzten Tage ist mir auch richtig ein bisschen schlecht
und mir ist auch so ein bisschen der Appetit vergangen, muss ich sagen.
Ich bin wirklich, ich fühle mich richtig krank dadurch.
Seit drei oder vier Tagen.
Seit vier Tagen.
Sie haben keinen Appetit mehr.
Ja genau.
Haben Sie noch Nackensteifigkeit oder Muskelverspannung?
Bitte was?
Muskelverspannung oder Nacken?
Ja vielleicht, ich kann fast nicht bewegen den Kopf.
Ich muss immer so, wenn ich mich umdrehen will, muss ich immer alles mitdrehen.
Ja okay, okay.
Ich verstehe Frau Nykhoff, ich habe das bemerkt.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Wie beschreiben Sie, wobei nur kein Schmerzen,
zehn sehr sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Was würden Sie mir denn die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Also welchen Wert?
Oh, ja also über die Hälfte auf alle Fälle vielleicht, so bei sieben.
Sieben?
Okay.
Frau Nykhoff, Sie haben sehr sehr starke Schmerzen.
Möchten Sie noch eine Schmerzmittel?
Ja ich habe ja schon Ibuprofen genommen.
Das hat ein klein bisschen geholfen, aber richtig doll viel besser ist es nicht geworden, ja?
Ja, teilweise geholfen.
Und es war ganz angenehm, zu Hause habe ich dann mal,
weil ich versucht habe mich im Bett hinzulegen,
da habe ich mir dann so eine Wärme Kompresse dahin gemacht.
Im Ping ist es auch ein klein wenig besser.
Aber ja, das ist jetzt eben, weil es schon so lange ist,
ist es wirklich ein bisschen belastend, ja.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Beim Belastung oder beim Bewegung die Schmerzen verstärkt.
Ja, ich kann mich gar nicht bewegen, ja.
Ja und was ganz schwer ist, wenn ich im Bett liege die richtige Position zu finden,
deswegen schlafe ich auch noch schlecht.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Ich habe das natürlich.
Frau Nykhoff, gibt es eine bestimmte Auflöser für diese Schmerzen?
Ich könnte nicht sagen, also ich, was weiß ich,
also ich kann das nicht sagen, was das ausgelöst hat, wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Zum Beispiel, früher haben Sie etwas Schweres hochgeheben oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Oder stärker Sport treiben?
Nein, also so viel Sport mache ich jetzt nicht.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie Ibuprofen angenommen?
Drei Mal.
Drei Mal?
Ja.
Okay, Ibuprofen.
Und Frau Nykhoff, haben Sie Kribbeln, Taubeidgefühl oder gibt es ähnliche Beschwerden?
Seit vier Tagen oder seit heute Morgen?
Nein, also wo soll es kribbeln?
Ich habe wahnsinnige Kopfschmerzen und diese Nackenschmerzen,
aber da kribbelt nichts.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Frau Nykhoff, früher haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, ich habe das noch nie gehabt, deswegen bin ich ja so...
Erstmal vor vier Tagen?
Ja, da hat es angefangen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und Frau Nykhoff, haben Sie Fieber?
Ich fühle mich jetzt nicht fiebrig, aber ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht gemessen.
Aber ich glaube, nein, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay, aber fühlen Sie sich ein bisschen fiebrig?
Nein, gar nicht.
Ich würde sagen, gar nicht.
Okay, Entschuldigung, ich habe fast verstanden.
Deswegen haben Sie keine Stellfrost nach Schweiß oder?
Nein, nein, schlecht schlafen kann ich nur, weil ich nicht weiß, wie ich liegen soll.
Und wenn ich versuche, mich umzudrehen,
dann muss ich vorher richtig überlegen, wie stelle ich das jetzt an.
Aber auch wenn ich morgens aufstehen will, wie komme ich jetzt aus dem Bett raus?
Ja, das ist ganz schwer.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ich frage mich eine sehr, sehr wichtige Frage für Sie.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Nein, nein, so etwas habe ich nicht.
Nein, okay.
Übelkeit?
Übel ist mir schon so ein bisschen, muss ich schon sagen.
Aber vielleicht auch, weil ich einfach nicht gut esse,
weil es mir nicht schmeckt und ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, kein Appetit mehr.
Und dann, ja, okay, ich habe das notiert.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Gar nicht, okay.
Super.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, normalerweise gar nicht.
Aber jetzt auch nicht.
Okay, alles gut.
Haben Sie Husten oder?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn ich Husten müsste, würde mir das weh tun, ja.
Okay.
Ihre Periode ist regelmäßig?
Ja, die ist zwangsläufig regelmäßig, weil ich eine Pille nehme.
Pille?
Seit wann haben Sie Pille eingenommen?
Seit wann?
Ja, regelmäßig.
Ja, klar, die muss man ja regelmäßig nehmen, sonst hilft sie nicht.
Okay, okay.
Aber die nehme ich schon jetzt jahrelang.
Okay.
Alles gut.
Und dann?
Frau Niehoff, leiden Sie an irgendwelchen kranken Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder sowas?
Gott sei Dank nicht, ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
Ich hoffe, ich bleibe auch noch eine Weile gesund, ja.
Ja, super.
Super, schön.
Frau Niehoff, würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, tatsächlich hatte ich mal einen Unfall.
Da hatte ich einen komplizierten Bruch im linken Unterarm.
Das ist damals mit einer Platte versorgt worden.
Das war natürlich die OP, und dann ist das Metall irgendwann wieder rausgekommen.
Ja.
Der Unfall, das war vor zwölf Jahren?
Zwölf Jahre.
Sie haben schon gesagt, mit Platte.
Ja, genau.
Die Platte ist schon da, oder?
Nee, die ist nachher entfernt worden.
Nachher entfernt?
Ja.
Gibt es noch?
Sonst bin ich noch nie operiert.
Okay, okay.
Frau Niehoff, haben Sie schon gesagt, nehmen Sie bei Bedarf Ibuprofen.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Nee, sonst, wie gesagt nur die Pille, aber so?
Pille, und Pille regeln, dann ist Ibuprofen bei Bedarf.
Ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen kennt man ja,
wenn man viel gearbeitet hat oder ein bisschen zu lange in der Sonne war,
oder es ein bisschen anstrengender Tag war,
dann habe ich schon mal leichte Kopfschmerzen,
aber nicht so etwas wie jetzt.
Okay, okay.
Ibuprofen 400?
Nee, 600er habe ich da immer.
600er, okay 600er.
Ist gut.
Und dann, Frau Niehoff, rauchen Sie, oder?
Ich rauche ganz, ganz wenig.
Also eigentlich bin ich nur so ein Gelegenheitsraucher.
So ein Päckchen in der Woche rauche ich ungefähr.
Ein Päckchen in einer Woche.
Ja.
Also ich rauche eigentlich immer nur in den Pausen,
wenn die Kollegen rausgehen, dann rauche ich aus Gesellschaft eine mit,
aber ich brauche jetzt nicht ständig eine Zigarette, nee.
Ja, können Sie jetzt versuchen mit dem Rauchen komplett aufzuwöhnen?
Ja, wäre vielleicht ein Versuch wert, ja.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol, Frau Niehoff?
Ja, also ich trinke gerne mal ein Glas Wein.
Ja, also nicht regelmäßig, also nicht jeden Tag oder so,
aber was ich am Wochenende oder auch mal,
ja wenn es ein besonders gutes Essen gibt,
wenn mal Essen geht oder wenn man eingeladen ist,
dann trinke ich schon gerne mal ein Glas Wein, ja.
Okay, ein Glas Wein.
Okay.
Frau Niehoff, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine ganz, ganz routine Frage.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert?
Nee, also das habe ich tatsächlich noch nie.
Okay, Drogen.
Frau Niehoff, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die leben beide noch, ja.
Frau Niehoff, bitte hören.
Ihr Vater ist gesund?
Naja, gesund kann man auch nicht sagen,
der hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Herzinfarkt,
aber der ist mit einem Stent versorgt worden
und seitdem geht es dem ganz gut.
Jetzt unter Kontrolle.
Ja, ja, das wird natürlich ständig kommen,
da muss irgendwelche Medikamente, so Blutverdünner nehmen,
die da weiter durch Blutet bleiben und so,
aber jetzt geht es dem eigentlich erstaunlich gut, ja.
Okay, okay, sehr, sehr gut. Und Ihre Mutter?
Ja, die ist eigentlich auch noch recht rüstig und fit,
die hatte allerdings einmal eine Knieoperation,
weil sie also Gelenkverschleiß hat, ja.
Wie alt ist sie?
Oh, wie alt ist sie? Sie ist 72.
72.
Frau Niehoff, haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich.
Eine Schwester, ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Gott sei Dank sehr, sehr gut.
Und Frau Niehoff, sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet.
Leidig. Und haben Sie Kinder?
Auch keine Kinder, nein.
Keine Kinder.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Beruflich? Ich bin Büroangestellte,
ich arbeite hier im Rathaus.
Rathaus, Büroangestellte, okay.
Frau Niehoff, wie viele Stunden arbeiten Sie täglich?
Ja, also 7,5 Stunden am Tag, ja.
Und halt sehr viel Computerarbeit, ne?
Ja, immer.
Computerarbeit und so.
Frau Niehoff, haben Sie noch Sechstörungen?
Nee, nee.
Gucken kann ich nach wie vor gut.
Haben Sie noch aktuell keine Kribbel-Taubeitgefühle?
Kein, nee, kein Taubeitgefühle.
Ich wüsste nicht wo, nein, hier ist nichts taub, ja.
Haben Sie nur Nacken- und Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, diese Nacken und ja,
und das zieht halt auch bis in den Arm,
also ich kann mich eigentlich ganz schlecht bewegen.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und die Schmerzen strahlen den linken Arm aus?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wissen Sie, deswegen war ich jetzt heute nicht bei der Arbeit,
weil man mit so einem Kopf wirklich so nicht am Computer arbeiten kann.
Es geht einfach nicht, man, ich hab solche Wahnsinns-Kopfschmerzen, ne?
Ja, ich verstehe, ich verstehe.
Okay.
Frau Niehoff, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Und haben Sie noch Fragen an mich, oder?
Ja, woher kann das denn kommen und was machen Sie denn jetzt?
Ja, Frau Niehoff,
ich habe den Verdacht auf eine Hans-Wilbert-Säule-Müskeverspannung.
Und...
Was kann man dagegen tun?
Ja, Sie haben ein Büro eingestellt.
Sie arbeiten immer am Computer.
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Täglich leben und...
Machen Sie regelmäßig Pause, oder?
Ja, also Mittagspause machen wir natürlich und zwischendurch trinken wir einen Kaffee
und ja, dann eben diese Rauchpause, ne, wenn wir mal rausgehen zwischendurch, ne?
Okay, okay, ich verstehe, okay.
Meine Verdacht auf Hans-Wilbert-Säule-Müskeverspannung,
aber natürlich, das bleibt nur eine Vermutung
und ich werde Ihnen zuerst körperlich untersuchen,
dann ein wenig Blut abnehmen
und einen Röntgen, zwei Ebenen durchführen.
Ein Röntgen?
Ja, Röntgen.
Welche Ebenen werden gerönt? Was wird geröntgt?
Zwei Ebenen, alle vorne und seitlich.
Ja, und was wird geröntgt?
Was wird geröntgt?
Ja, Röntgen ist ein Schmerz.
Nein, was? Nicht...
Ja.
Welcher Körperteil wird geröntgt?
Ja, Hans-Wilbert-Säule.
Ach, die Hans-Wilbert-Säule.
Kann man das nur so gezielt, das war nur das kleine Stück?
Zwei Ebenen, Hans und ja, zwei Ebenen, vorne und seitlich.
Von der Seite und von vorne, jetzt habe ich es verstanden, ja.
Und dann ein Röntgen-Torax.
Und, also wie...
Die ganze Brust wird auch geröntgt?
Ja.
Okay, na gut, okay.
Und ein wenig Blut abnehmen,
dann ein EKG
Und dann einen orthopädischen Konsil anfinden.
Okay, ja.
Sobald ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen,
bespreche ich jetzt das mit meinem Obarzt
und dann komme ich sofort zurück zu ihnen
und dann erzähle ich Schritt für Schritt,
was man machen kann.
Ja, das ist gut, das klingt doch gut, ja.
Okay, danke schön.
Gerne, Frau Mioff, sollen Sie ein bisschen hier bleiben
und dann komme ich.
Sehr gut, okay, nun ja, danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Möchte jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen stellen?
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Kopfbereich verletzt?
Kopfbereich?
Haben Sie irgendwelche Verletzungen?
Nein, ob ich schon mal...
Nein, also nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Entschuldigung, habe ich mir meine Beule geholt,
oder so, ja, am Kopf.
Aber das ist schon lange her,
also ich habe mich jetzt nicht irgendwo verletzt.
Danke schön.
Frau Mioff?
Ja?
Hat Ihre Blutdruck noch mal gemessen?
Ja, das wird, wenn ich zum Hausarzt gehe,
zum Checkup, dann wird der Blutdruck mal gemessen,
aber so viel ich weiß, ist der immer so normal.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie sehr Störungen?
Nein, gucken kann ich gut, ja.
Also hat er aber auch gefragt gerade.
Ja.
Das ist gut.
Danke.
Ja, gerne.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Ja, alles gut.
Ja, ganz...
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen,
wenn Sie Zeit haben, ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich, wen haben Sie gesehen?
Es geht um Antje Niehoff,
38-jähriger Patient,
geboren am 1.8.1967,
1,87 Meter.
Hallo, hallo?
1967 nicht.
Wenn sie 38 Jahre ist,
87, ne?
Ja, 85.
Ah, ich weiß, wo sie die 67 Jahre haben.
Ich habe sie nicht genannt.
Und 1,67 Meter.
Da kommt sie, die 67.
Ja, schon 30 Jahre.
Und 63 Kilo.
Mhm, also so eine schlanke Patientin.
Frau Niehoff stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen der 3 Tagen bestehenden,
langsam aufgetretenen, brennenden
Kopf-Nackenschmerzen
und Kopfschmerzen vor.
Mhm.
Die Schmerzen vor 3 Tagen langsam
aufgetreten und die Schmerzstrahlen
Nacken, Hals und linken Arm aus.
Und die Schmerzintensität liegt
7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Und seit 3 Tagen klagt über
wegen der Schmerzen eine Schlafstörung
und nach der Einnahme von Ibuprofen
eine Übelkeit.
Also die Übelkeit kommt von den Schmerztabletten?
Ja.
Ich habe es so notiert.
Und ansonsten die Bekämpfung des Amnes
ist unaufwählig.
Keine Fieber, kein Herzklopfen,
kein Herzrasen oder Schwinde
die Fragen nach würde verleihen.
Und als Vorerkrankungen
Sie hatte keine Vorerkrankungen.
Keine Vorerkrankungen? Ok, gesunde Patienten, ja.
Bei der Voroperation des Amnes
bei ihr würde mit 12. Lebensjahr
wegen einer linken Unterarmbruch
eine Operation durchgeführt.
Machen Sie einmal tun Sie mir den Gefallen
nehmen Sie aber Fachbegriff.
Ja.
Und nachher, ein paar nachher
die Platten entfernt.
Also es gab eine Plattenostiosynthese
bei einer Unterarmkaktur?
Ja, die linken Unterarme
aus der Synthese durchgeführt
mit Platten
und nachher wurde entfernt.
Ja, ok.
Und sie nimmt bei Bedarf Ibuprofen
600 Tabletten
und regelmäßig Pille ein.
Bei der Noxen-Anamnese
Nikotinkonsum wurde
eine Packung pro Woche bejaht
Alkoholkonsum, ein oder zwei Gläserbein
am Wochenende wurde bejaht
Drogenkonsum wurde verleint
Die Familienanamnese ergab
Herzinfarkt bei der Vater
zwei Jahre
Mute hat eine Knieoperation
mit zwei siebzig Lebensjahren
und sie ist
Büroangestalt beim Rathaus
arbeitet am Computer
mindestens sieben oder acht Stunden
sie ist ledig, kein Kind
Aufgrund der Anamnese
habe ich den Verdacht auf
Hans Wirbel soll Muskelverspannung
Was könnte es differenzialdiagnostisch sein?
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen
Hans Wirbel soll die Bandscheibe vorfahren
und Akute Coronas syndrome in Betracht
Ja, haben Sie noch mehr
Differenzialdiagnosen, könnte noch mehr sein
Noch mehr sein, ja
Denken Sie mal Worst Case
Ja, Kronische Kopfschmerzen
noch eine Differenzialdiagnose, Migraine
Zum Beispiel, ja
Migraine
Und dann
Heftige Kopfschmerzen, Nacken nicht beweglich
Geht es Ihnen so?
Ja, das wäre ein schlechter Fall
Dafür geht es Ihnen aber eigentlich zu gut, würde ich auch sagen
Als Differenzialdiagnose sollten wir das auf alle Fälle
auf dem Zettel haben
Gut, was machen Sie jetzt mit der Patientin?
Ich werde als erstes eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Neurologische Untersuchung
Ja, was im Einzelnen?
Besonders
Bewegung, Kapazität
Bewertung
und Reflexuntersuchung
Ja, welche Reflexe zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel Nackensteifigkeit
Okay, mhm
Ja, das sind ja keine Reflexe
Aber neurologisch, welche Reflexe checken Sie?
Ja, zum Beispiel Triceps oder Biceps
Reflexe, die in der körperlichen Maske sind
Huch, was haben wir hier?
Triceps
Und dann
Ja
Gut, was machen Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Haben Sie gerade gesagt Nackensteifigkeit checken Sie?
Ja, bei der neurologischen Untersuchung
Ja, zum Beispiel, mir fällt nicht ein, aber
Augenuntersuchung
Ja, Pupillenreflexe
Pupillenreflexe und
Und sicherlich sollten Sie, die Patientin hat zwar gesagt
Hat sie Kribbelparastäsin angegeben?
Nee, die Patientin hat nicht angegeben
Aber das sollten Sie auf alle Fälle überprüfen, ne?
Ja, natürlich
Ob Mobilität, gerade in dem linken Arm
Ob Mobilität und Sensibilität, ob das da ist, ne?
Ja, natürlich
Gut, ja, dann was machen Sie außer der neurologischen Untersuchung
Also, um haben Ihrer Untersuchung weiter?
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung
Nee, weiter bei der sonstigen Untersuchung
Ja, und dann
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung
Ich werde einen Blut
Im Labor abnehmen
Blut fürs Labor abnehmen, was lassen Sie untersuchen?
Blutlabor abnehmen, Blutbild
Und Ersündungsparameter
Und Leber und Nierenmärte
Und Herzensüme
Ja, und der Vater hat einen Herzkrankenstil
Und deswegen möchte ich diese Option beurteilen
Tropenöl, T und Öl
Und ein ruhiges EKG
Ja, genau
Gut, und was machen Sie sonst noch?
Diagnostik, operative Diagnostik?
Operative Diagnostik möchte ich
Erstmal einen orthopädischen
Physikalischen und Konsil
Anfragen und dann
Einen MRT veranlassen
Gleich mit dem MRT loslegen
Oder erst was anderes?
Der Patientin haben Sie gerade was anderes gesagt
Patientin, ja
Da haben Sie nichts von dem MRT erzählt
Was haben Sie der gesagt?
Ja, Röhr Untersuchung
Bitte was?
Röhr Untersuchung
Erstmal einen Röhrndkern
Ja, das haben Sie noch nicht gesagt
Gut, also die Patientin muss geröhrt werden
Die HWS, ja, genau
HWS und ein Thorax
Röhr und dann gegebenenfalls
Wenn das nicht klar ist, dann kann man
Noch einen MRT hinterherschieben, genau, gut
Wenn es sich tatsächlich rausstellt, dass sie
Nur, in Anführungszeichen
Also eine Muskelverspannung hat
Und dadurch eine Reizung
Was wäre dann die Therapie?
Als erste Patientin würde ich gerne
Anarchetikum
Und was noch?
Muskelrelaktant
Was könnte man noch machen?
Und eine physikalische Rehabilitation
Und Patientenschulung
Bitte was?
Patientenschulung
Ja, genau
Also physikalische Therapie
Im Sinne von Krankengymnastik oder Wärmeanwendung
Ich fange schon an, mir selber die Nacken zu...
Ja, also Wärmeanwendung
Möglicherweise Massagen
Und eben auch Gymnastik
Und wichtig genau der Punkt
Unter Umständen Arbeitsplatzkontrolle
Dass man sagt
Ist der Computer richtig eingestellt
Ist der Stuhl richtig
Ist die Richtung zum Licht richtig und Pipapo
Genau
Ja, vielen Dank
Ich bin gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt
Hoffen wir mal, dass es nichts Schlimmes ist
Und dann sehen wir uns, wenn Sie mit Ihren Untersuchungen abgeschlossen haben
Dann berichten Sie mir bitte noch einmal über die Patientin
Ja?
Alles klar, gut
Ja
Wir können gleich zur Besprechung gehen
Natürlich sprechen Sie sehr gut Deutsch
Muss man sagen, kein Problem
Was ich sehr nett fand, Sie haben die Patientin immer wieder mit Namen angesprochen
Das ist schön
Und Sie haben auch
Zumindest ist mir nichts anderes aufgefallen
Sie haben sehr schön differenziert gefragt
Sie haben nicht nur haben Sie, haben Sie, haben Sie
Sondern ich meine, das war sehr
Abwechslungsreich
Und ich habe mich als Patient immer gut aufgerufen gefühlt
Sie haben zum Beispiel gut zugehört
Was ich schon gesagt habe
Da haben Sie gesagt, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie das und das haben
Und dann
Wie ist es
Also das haben Sie wirklich super gemacht
Es waren
Ein paar ganz winzig kleine Sachen
Die mir aufgefallen sind
Augenblick
Ja, zwei Sachen haben Sie gar nicht gefragt
Allergien haben Sie nicht gefragt
Und Impfstatus haben Sie nicht gefragt
Ja, könnte höchstens im Zusammenhang
Vielleicht mit
FSME-Impfung
Meningitis Sommerzeit
Nur mal so am Rande
Ich habe schon die erste Zecke Intus
Und habe tatsächlich auch schon
Ich bin geimpft gegen FSME
Hab aber Antibiotika bekommen wegen Borreliose
Die Zecken sind schon unterwegs
Muss man mit rechnen
Also Impfstatus wäre wichtig
Ist natürlich immer auch noch Covid interessant
Und Allergien wäre auch noch wichtig
Nachzufragen
Das ist überhaupt nicht gekommen
Ansonsten waren Sie in der Fragestellung
Wirklich richtig gut
Im Bericht hatten wir sprachlich
Ein paar
Vom Verständnis her ein paar
Problemchen
Das erste hat sich geklärt
71, 67 und Jahrgang 67
Klar, wenn die 38 Jahre alt ist
Dann ist sie Jahrgang 87
Mir ist dabei mit Schrecken aufgefallen
Mein ältester Sohn ist
Jahrgang 88
Verdammte Hacke, ja
Dieses Jahr 38
Wir altern mit unseren Kindern
Die Mutter hatte eine Knie-OP
Sie haben gefragt, wie alt ist die Mutter
Da hat die gesagt, Anfang 70
Die Knie-OP war schon länger her
Sie haben nicht gefragt, wie alt war die Mutter
Bei der Operation
Aber sie haben es nachher beim Oberarzt
Mit 70 Jahren wurde die Mutter operiert
Das ist die Tücke
Das kommt gleich noch einmal
Mit unserer Zeitangabe
Diese Unterarmfraktur
Links mit Plattenversorgung
Das war vor 12 Jahren
Das war nicht
Mit im 12. Lebensjahr
Das ist ein großer Unterschied
Da muss man wirklich aufpassen
Das ist ein Fehler
Den aber sehr viele
Nicht Muttersprachler machen
Das ist sehr kompliziert im Deutschen
Diese Zeitangaben
Wir müssen unterscheiden, vor 12 Jahren
Mit 12 Jahren
Seit 12 Jahren
Das beschreibt eine Zeitdauer
Vor 12 Jahren ist ein Zeitpunkt
Mit 12 Jahren wäre auch ein Zeitpunkt
Aber eben ein verkehrter
Da bitte Vorsicht
Damit sie nicht in die Falle laufen
Das ist mir auch noch aufgefallen
Sie haben gesagt, die Patientin hätte die Übelkeit
Nach dem Ibuprofen bekommen
Das hat die aber nicht gesagt
Das hat die so nicht gesagt
Sie hat 3-mal Ibuprofen genommen
Die Übelkeit hat sie jetzt halb
Weil sie starke Schmerzen hat
Das vermutet sie jetzt
Weil sie nicht viel gegessen hat
Weil sie schlapp im Magen ist
Weil sie keinen Appetit hat
Übelkeit und Appetitlosigkeit
Diese beiden Dinge haben sie
Diese Appetitlosigkeit haben sie nicht erwähnt
Und ich hatte
Da eigentlich auch noch mal gedacht
Sie könnten ein bisschen im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch
Mehr auf die Fachbegriffe gehen
Dass sie eben sagen
Persistierende Kopfschmerzen
Dass sie sagen
Persistierende Zephalgie
Oder dass sie eben sagen Inappetenz
Gerade die Düsseldorfer
Die stehen total auf Fachbegriffe
Muss man wirklich so sagen
Insofern auch unterarm Fraktur links
Nicht
Plattenlostereosynthese
Das ist schon wichtig
Genauso wie dann eben orales Kontrazeptivum
Logischerweise macht das
Einen regulären Zyklus
Haben sie übrigens auch nicht gefragt
Regelmäßige gynäkologische Kontrollen
Sollte man auch bei jüngeren Frauen
Tatsächlich auch noch mal abfragen
Dann natürlich
HWS-Syndrom ist die richtige Diagnose
Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema
Die ist die richtige Diagnose
Wir haben als Differentialdiagnose
Einen Diskusprolaps
Wir haben die Migräne
Wobei das keine ganz typische Migräne ist
Die so lange dauert
Und die auch ohne Seestörungen abläuft
Das ist ja eigentlich
Die Migräne hat ja so ein klassisches Bild
Und natürlich
Worse case auch ein Tumor
Könnte auch schlimmstenfalls sein
Aber tatsächlich
Diese Patientin hat jetzt
HWS-Syndrom
Da kam natürlich auch alles, was wir wissen wollten
Neurologische Untersuchung, Blutbild
Körperliche Untersuchung
Beweglichkeit
Wo ist mein Doktor? Hilfe
Er ist wieder da
Körperliche Untersuchung
Mobilität, Beweglichkeit
Nackensteifigkeit
Das sind die entscheidenden Punkte
Und natürlich dann auch Röntgen, HWS
Und dann auch genau richtig
So würde ich sagen, das war eine sehr schöne Anamnese
Eine sehr gute Wiedergabe
Mit Kleinigkeiten
Aber nicht unwichtigen Kleinigkeiten
Die vielleicht so als Tipp für die Prüfung
Noch wichtig sind eben diese Zeitangaben
Und die Fachbegriffe
Das wäre das einzige als Schönheitsfehler
Würde ich mal so sagen
Können Sie sich glaube ich beruhigt zurücklehnen
Und Ihrer Prüfung entgegensehen
Vielen Dank
Ich dachte darauf
Soviel für heute, für heute Abend
Schönen Dank fürs Mitmachen
Schönen Dank fürs Zuhören